job aiden deja medio oriente con las
manos vacías pero con palabras de
compromiso en la región en la que
pretende mantener su influencia y alejar
las de rusia y china unicom en clayton
me está quedando claro cuán
estrechamente unidos están los intereses
estadounidenses con el éxito en medio
oriente
fueron agua
y no nos vamos a ningún lado y no
dejaremos un vacío que puedan llenar
china rusia o irán
vamos a construir sobre este momento un
activo liderazgo estadounidense en su
último día de gira 'bye den se reunió
con los líderes de irak egipto y
emiratos árabes unidos- y participó en
una cumbre del consejo de cooperación
del golfo entre los principales temas
estuvieron la influencia de irán en la
región y las intenciones de washington
de integrar a israel como parte de un
nuevo eje para contrarrestar la
influencia de teherán una propuesta que
no gustó a riad no esté de sus foros
jones y foros el sur con swiss eeuu
apoyará y fortalecerá las alianzas con
países que suscriben el orden
internacional y nos aseguraremos de que
estos países puedan defenderse de
ataques internacionales durante la gira
el tema que copó los titulares fue su
saludo con el príncipe heredero de
arabia saudita mohamed bin salman aquí
en la diplomacia estadounidense culpa
del asesinato del periodista llama al
hayyi el encuentro generó críticas pues
contradecía las promesas de bailén en su
campaña electoral
aseguró que convertiría a riad en un
paria internacional baiden llegó a
arabia saudita con la esperanza de
alcanzar un acuerdo sobre la producción
de petróleo para ayudar a reducir los
precios de la gasolina que han llevado
la inflación en eeuu a máximos de 40
años por el momento no se consiguió un
acuerdo pero washington espera encontrar
apoyo de riad y otros gobiernos del
golfo en esta materia